hi guys it's me Batman Rock and today
I'm at BuzzFeed to read your thirst
tweets but before I do make sure you
guys visit your nearest Ulta and your
nearest drugstore near you to check out
my wet n wild collection called jungle
rock let me know if you guys like it but
wait it's sold out you might not be even
be able to get it let's begin Bremen
Rock has better eyebrows than the entire
female population and that's actual
facts honestly she speaks facts
honestly I really don't think I have
really nice eyebrows but thank you for
thinking so but if you want nice
eyebrows I really recommend shaving them
off and waiting for them to grow back
because they go back thicker but if they
don't don't sue me I want Batman Rock to
tap-dance on my throat that's it that's
the tweet I don't really know how to
tap-dance but I'll do some you know hula
or teeny cling on your throw if you want
me to do then he clean as a Filipino
folklore dance if you guys uneducated
and uncultured bradman rock a different
type of thing I want him to crush my
skull with his eyes oh my god did you
guys watch that one video with a girl
was like crushing watermelon would hurt
but she went roll the clip
Bremen Rock has inspired me to put a
stripper pole in my living room I love
that I even inspired myself so I can
relate to you same could people ask me
all the time like what inspired you to
get a stripper pole on your house I'm
like I inspired myself no one put a gun
on my head like imagine JLo after
hustler dream and Shipibo and your
mother living room no I just got Harley
and I ordered on Amazon Bremen Rock is
sexy ASF I saw I'm glad he gay and
embracing all of it but girl when he
pulled some pics of him with no makeup
and looking straight question mark I
lost it
dude is so fine period any guy who gets
him is blessed
fine and funny oh my god I don't know
reaction to that but thank you so much
it was a very expressive tweet I thought
every word that you said but yes thank
God I'm gay I'm y'all honestly any guy
that would be
is lucky so you hear that boo oh my god
my man didn't watch my videos but if you
are Bremen rock with makeup is a bad dr.
doe and Brett man with DA makeup it's
daddy
uh oh my god I hate that word like if
you ever tweet daddy and greteman rock
in one mother sentence I'm reporting
that tweet call me Mommy Sunstein daddy
daddy daddy daddy
you can call this daddy though like I
really put up let me just talk to per
second I really put on makeup for two
hours for you to call me daddy for you
to mother call me daddy does this
contour scream daddy - you haven't been
on bremenn rocks IG Paige that's not my
problem in a while and I come back to
him being a dummy thing uh I shut choke
me daddy
okay just cuz it's not daddy and you
change it to Zadi doesn't mean stop
calling me that sometimes I think
Bradman rock is a skinny twink but then
I remembered he's a buff ass who could
strangle me with a Gucci belt first of
all it would be like not a Gucci belt
it'd be like Hermes Bell Gucci though
then stomp on me with a Louboutin
stiletto boots that sounds about right
I want one day with Bremen Rock so he
can make me laugh I can't eat his
foreign food later that night and he can
sit on my face if you give me foreign
food you do not want me to stay on your
face I'm trying to capture the verse
energy that Bremen Rock possesses
anniversary would have said that who is
starting these rumors about me I'm not
verse I'm not a top either so feelin the
line I get my girl to call me Bremen
rock while we harder Patman rock harder
yo
Alois so I had a dream last night that
me and Bremen Brock vote up to a hotel
orgy party but instead locked ourselves
in the bathroom and bid a face mask and
many patties Mia's oh my god me if I
went to a hotel or Jakarta to be honest
top T's Bremen Rock can destroy this bus
he period I read that a little too
confident okay top T's Bremen Rock can
destroy this bus see that period dot oh
that's so cute
I think I really liked how you put
period period and period I would let
Bremen rock wreck my don't at me
I won't I really won't I really won't
actually that's last thing I do
but the answer is no I've been peepin
Brandon Rock lifting weights and looking
masculine in his insta picks and I just
gotta say I'd smash honestly I feel like
nowadays all you have to do is lift
weight and look mass to get smashed
last one let's support us out
there's gotta be guys bradman rocks but
it's bigger than my mother future her
honestly yeah not that I know what your
future looks like but I do have a fat
arse so that has been reading tweets
with BuzzFeed thank you so much for
watching let me know if you guys want
more videos and I won't be adding any of
y'all
[Music]
[Music]